andrew cuomo is not the only
democratic governor in trouble right now
gavin newsom
is also in trouble gavin newsom is
governor
patrick bateman from california governor
american psycho over there in my old
state and when i say they're in trouble
yes they're in trouble but not nearly
the sort of trouble they'd be in if they
were republicans and maybe not
politically terminal trouble you know
maybe they'll be able to survive this
what they really do i find they just
flaunt their power so gavin newsom got
in trouble a few months ago
because he ordered all these lockdown
rules and his mandates and shutting down
businesses and restaurants then what
does he do
he shows up with his friends to the
french laundry a michelin rated
restaurant
these meals that for the french laundry
are often thousand dollars a plate
sometimes more
he shows up he's sitting right next to
his friends looked pretty indoors to me
shoulder to shoulder no one's wearing
masks and they're all laughing and
having a good time and they're all
laughing at us because we believe the
kind of nonsense that they're spouting
about how we need to stay home and
social distance and all that
stuff that they themselves are not are
not following
so newsome got in trouble for that but
he survived now he posted another video
with george lopez the
sitcom star from the 2000s you know he
kind of
now all he does is really turn up in
political videos
and he's he's inside a restaurant with
george lopez they're wearing masks
but they're inside a restaurant in an
area that is supposed to have
closed no indoor dining
how do i find out if i can get a
vaccination
george you got to go to my turn.ca.gov
wait a minute thank you governor
it's wonderful to be a surface george
first of all just 100 pure
grade a cringe in the video right i mean
that's that is so
they're like hello hey fellow tick
talkers hello
how do you do fellow kids uh but beyond
that
what are they doing in that restaurant
what are they doing they're not supposed
to be in that restaurant
in that county in that area so they're
inside there well maybe they're just
there for a film shoot right
well they were they were sort of posting
some pictures it looks like they had
some food there
i actually the way i know they had some
food there is because when you film
anything you have craft services so that
the crew and cast members can eat
so you got new sim again i think it is
not
unfair to infer
he's certainly inside a restaurant so
he's already breaking that rule and
i suspect they might have had a bite or
two to eat
i suspect that's what the photos sort of
suggest they just
flaunt their power and they know that
they're gonna
not get into any trouble for this if you
enjoyed that video be sure to hit the
subscribe button so everyone waiting
through the wasteland of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there
[Music]
you